[Music]
you know that song it's one of the most
iconic characters in video game history
and it's making a new jump to the big
screen Mario the Italian plumber who
first appeared in 1981 has evolved from
a pixelated blob to the star of a new
film out this week Jamie Yuka shows us
why the love from Mario crosses
Generations
her Mario Brothers movie the mustachioed
plumber alongside all your favorite
characters
yeah
yeah okay is taking audiences on an
adventure
as they work to free his brother Luigi
from the grip of the evil dragon like
turtle Bowser and save the Mushroom
Kingdom
[Music]
Mario's mission is quite familiar to
video game fans who have been guiding
him over fires
downplay polls and through race tracks
for 40 years
foreign
first as a character called Jumpman in
Donkey Kong then is Mario in Nintendo's
Mario Brothers arcade game what is the
Everlasting appeal and Legacy of Mario
wow that's a good question I mean the
simple joy of it is really the appeal of
it I I think people have such a strong
connection to him welcome back to New
rockstars this is the big question it's
Eric Voss knows Mario his new Rockstar's
YouTube channel celebrates nerd culture
what people are really excited about
with this Mario movie is the fact that
they have kept that authenticity and
that luster and that color and that
vibrancy as the Mario Universe has
expanded so has the main character's
versatility he appears in games as not
just a plumber but as a referee a doctor
a golfer and of course a high-speed
driver but aside from the technology
little else about Mario and his story
has changed the same kind of comfort
food effect of Mario has been there from
the beginning and we just root for this
guy we root for these characters we love
them and there's a Simplicity to them
it was the first real video game that
kind of told the story it got Mario It's
Gonna Save The Princess and and fight
against Donkey Kong in the film Jack
Black plays Bowser now who's gonna stop
her they slowly over the decades have
built this huge Universe of characters
and story lines that is really
unparalleled in the world of video games
that world is now more than just a
virtual reality at Super Nintendo World
in Los Angeles Mario is Center Stage
fans can travel through warp pipes Meet
Mario friends in the flesh and bond over
a shared love of the franchise what was
it like coming in here today oh my gosh
it was awesome Connor parlette's parents
introduced him to the wide world of
Mario when he was just seven is it kind
of funny that these games are still out
that your mom plays yeah I know like
what it's life what the heck this is so
old Gil boltron is visiting for the
first time with his two kids sahana and
Simi is it fun that there is that little
piece of nostalgia that you can share
with your kids definitely having them
play the game with me just brings me
back to my cousins sitting around for
people here at the theme park in Los
Angeles and in movie theaters across the
country this week it's about the thrill
of reconnecting with the characters who
have always been there for us there's no
shame in the game of Mario you you can
be any age and jump back into this world
and feel like you're meeting some
friends that you haven't talked to in a
while and that timelessness says Vos is
part of the enduring appeal it's just
like you know putting on an old sitcom
on a streamer on a on a Friday night
like you could watch hundreds and
hundreds of hours of that and that's
kind of what Mario is
ah so whether you're watching him on the
big screen
guiding him on your TV Mario has proven
that anyone even a little pixelated
plumber from Brooklyn can make it big
they understand what works and what
people love about the games from setting
a race on Rainbow Road they just know
what fans want for CBS mornings Jamie
yukas Los Angeles
Who's Gonna See It come on I think I got
to see it for sure hands down the number
one video game franchise oh my God I
remember in 1981 like when it came out
in like going to the candy shop yeah and
you're stuffing quarters quarters
quarters quarters quarters and Donkey
Kong trying to get Mario to the top and
I think the animation has come to now
amazing pixelated Mario I played it on
the old school Nintendo where you just
take the game out when it got stuck yeah
yeah yeah
and put it back in and hope that it
works back on my 80s babies knows what
I'm talking yeah I remember that
everybody knows I'm talking about uh the
Super Mario Brothers movie is in
theaters now so check it out